well i often tell the story that uh when
i
met a new acquaintance many years ago
and they asked about my family
i said um dylan's gonna have a great
life he's uh smart
he's athletic he's good looking and he
has lots of friends he'll be able to do
whatever he wants it was barely a month
ago
that dylan buckner took his own life
whatever stereotypes people might have
about kids that commit suicide
you know however it's portrayed in tv or
movies
was just not our experience with dylan
at all it was a very silent
very invisible killer that
didn't come to our attention until he
made his first suicide attempt in
september
and the family says school closures due
to the pandemic
played a part you know 450 000 people
and counting in the us have died of
covid
and that's a terrible thing but um i'm
fortunate
in that i don't know um any of any of
those people but i do know one person
who committed suicide
i learned after his first suicide
attempt while his depression
predates covid there really is no doubt
in my mind that the lockdowns the
isolation the lack of in-person
schooling the lack of
in-person interaction with his friends
the lack of football
absolutely contributed to his death and
dylan's family isn't alone
america the debate over whether it's
safe to reopen schools
now can't avoid what experts say is a
mental health crisis
a rising number of suicides in some
places
cries for help everywhere
fewer than half of students have
returned to this high school in suburban
chicago
there is a quiet an emptiness here in
these rooms there are virtual
counselling sessions
and the demand has increased for the
students that struggled
we started to see students that uh you
know
started to really show up with signs of
depression differently than they had
before
everything from not being able to take
care of themselves to
just not getting out of bed doing school
from their bed
and then not engaging in the class at
all whether you're five years old or 17
this developmental phase is happening
so we have seen this before when
students have trauma in their lives
and have a trauma history in their lives
there are times where that developmental
process can be slowed and impacted
as schools everywhere work to reduce the
covid risk
even a full return to class could come
too late for some
i would think if i could predict the
future that for the next five to ten
years
we're going to see students come through
that have picked up trauma history
around this
that are continued need special support
here in schools
hi i'm diana boone and this is my
routine i wake up over there and i come
over to this desk area
students everywhere can probably
identify with diana for almost a year
now her bedroom
doubling as her classroom it's been
pretty difficult for me
especially staying remote this whole
time i haven't had that interaction with
other people
as i'm used to but the people who are
struggling are really struggling
sometimes
and they don't feel like they have that
support from the school because they
just don't understand it
we spoke to her on her doorstep about
that feeling of isolation
it's been hard some days but then i just
kind of think about hopefully this will
be over soon hopefully maybe there will
be a better day tomorrow and i just kind
of get myself through it
but there are sadly so many stories that
end like trevor's
he was awesome and i know moms say that
about their kids
because every mom thinks their kid's
awesome but i'm not the only one that
thought he was awesome
but being away from school changed him i
saw
some of his light go out a little bit um
it made him sad
it made him angry you know he um
he kind of felt lost he even told me he
felt lost
trevor took his own life in october his
family saw no warning signs
his mother says the isolation too much
for him
i think that the kids they need other
kids
they need to be involved they need to be
you know
they need to be in a classroom with
their teachers you know
it's you're missing all that
interpersonal stuff
that's very important i think
there's going to be a lot of ptsd from
this you know there is going to be a and
as a country we're not equipped to
handle
you know mental problems or mental
challenges at all
so i think we're going to have a fight
on our hands
if you read about depression if you read
about the signs of suicide you know many
of the symptoms
are not not going to be easy to see and
it's really important to talk to your
kids
you know really talk to them and for
kids it's really important for kids to
trust their parents they love you
unconditionally
and you know tell them about you know
how you're how you're feeling
um but it's also important too that
friends talk to friends i mean the
reality of it is is dylan
as much as we loved him and i think he
loved us and i think we were good
parents and had a very
strong family relationship you know just
couldn't open up to us
uh about his struggles in the same way
he could to his friends
i don't want anyone to have to go
through this
it is the worst it is the absolute worst
i just miss him a lot we all miss him
it's heart-wrenching for all of us
the reasons for any suicide of course
are complex and there are no easy
answers
but there are families who believe their
loss is just one more
awful hidden cost of this pandemic greg
milam sky news chicago